foreign
[Music]
briefing for Thursday April 20th I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
a cottage industry of people helping
would-be social media influencers to
develop their careers has blossomed in
the last few years
some younger people who may have once
aspired a social media stardom
themselves are finding it more lucrative
to take a supporting role one of them is
22 year old Amaya dami from Arizona
during the pandemic Demi lost her
internship at a marketing agency so she
decided to use her own experience on
social media to help small businesses
produce content for their social media
accounts in the last two years she says
she's grown her business obtaining
social into an annual six-figure
operation with a staff of three I spoke
with Amaya dami about her experience
Amaya what made you want to become a
social media manager as opposed to
becoming a social media influencer
yourself I've always been business
oriented and for me the influencing side
is still so young that nobody really
knows the true metrics of how much a
brand collab is or what they should be
charging or things like that so as that
continues to grow I think then it would
be easier to transition into more of the
influencing but since it was so young it
was something that I didn't feel like I
had enough control in it just over all
seemed like a more steady position for
me to have in my life so you're hired by
individuals or businesses who are
looking to grow their online presence
what kind of services do you offer so we
have three different types of plans we
have an Instagram based plan which is
just content so we'll just give you all
of the photo and video content you need
for Instagram for 30 days of posting
then we also have a tick tock plan as
well you're getting 25 videos which
means you're posting every day Monday
through Friday then we have one plan
that is called the obtaining social
package that plan is Tick Tock and
Instagram content and management so
basically you're just hands-free don't
have to do anything with social media we
will be dming your customers that DM you
posting all the content putting SEO on
it just really optimizing it for social
media while also having a person behind
your brand speaking to it and making
sure you're active at all times did
people are aware of how large the social
media economy social media ecosystem is
when talking with older Generations I
think that there is a little bit of a
skew there we're still in the earlier
stages of social media people will start
to see how beneficial it really is and
that TV isn't really what people are
watching nowadays they're scrolling
through Tick Tock they're on Instagram
and that is where you would want your
business to be it's where everybody's
eyes are what's next for you what's the
plan for the future I've actually
thought about that quite often and had
many conversations about this and I
continue to have that back and forth
about it I really do love helping small
businesses that really is my mission and
my goal and I do want to continue always
having that but if the personality side
of like my life were to shine more I do
think I would still be able to balance
that with my agency and kind of show
that as a case study and that's what
I've been able to do is show hey I'm
able to not only Market myself Market my
business but I'm able to Market you
Amaya dami is not the only person
embracing the business opportunities for
individuals created by social media and
as more young people aspire to be social
media stars there are plenty of
counterparts who see opportunities
taking on roles behind the camera and
off screen with me to discuss this is
wsj reporter Caitlin Roan so I think a
lot of people know that becoming a
social media influencer isn't just as
easy as you know taking a few selfies
and posting them online but it seems
like maybe it's particularly really hard
these days can you tell us why it was
very competitive now a lot of people
want to be influenced there is they see
this glamorous lifestyle oh like going
on brand trips going on vacations just
having fun with that and not knowing
that there's a lot of work behind the
scenes and that's where the
competitiveness has increased so it's
harder for people especially younger
people to get into these roles and be
relevant and keep that relevancy so now
we've got more people becoming social
media support staff I guess you'd call
them I mean what kind of roles are
people taking on there I found that a
lot of them are going to like video
editing photography like helping with
social media posts it's kind of like
Hollywood where you have people who want
to be like the actresses or the actors
but they can't be successful in that
career so they go into like producing or
filmmaking or a person behind the scenes
rather than the star per se so it's a
similar concept to that but with social
media so they're like advisors and
Consultants right and exactly like
better people who you go to when you
need to know what trend to do or to know
what outfit to wear in this video or how
the lighting should be you spoke with
people who've taken on these roles what
did they say about why they chose that
path as opposed to becoming just
influencers themselves a lot of them are
saying that that is not a lot of
stability with things staying within one
platform and with that it's like if
you're only on one platform it could be
gone by tomorrow
where would I go and a lot of them
saying that a business that supports and
influencer is more valuable and more
stable than doing the actual influencing
themselves and some of them also are
like introverted so a lot of them don't
want to be like the people in front of
the camera so I spoke with Ethan
Williams he is 20 years old and he made
doordash videos on Tick Tock just
showing his daily life as a doordasher
um and then he got some good engagement
on that one bit it had like over a
hundred thousand views but he noticed
that like it's never stable like you can
have 100 views one day and the next
thing you have like a thousand views and
he also is very introverted so he wanted
to find a way to like keep the social
media focused
um but a different angle and so he
decided to change it into video editing
into a business and since then he now
makes like three to four thousand a
month from his video editing business
there was a 2022 survey by higher
visibility a company that helps
businesses evaluate their online price
presence it found that of a thousand
people aged 18 to 25 27 said they plan
to be an influencer and nearly 15 said
that was their only career choice what
does that mean for the opportunities for
people who want to support influencers
so I spoke with a professor at Duke
University and he basically told me how
there is going to be a drastic demand
for this in the upcoming years people
are going to want to go into these
supporting roles people are going to be
video editors or photographers or social
media managers for these influencers
because it's going to be a big thing
what does all of that tell us about the
social media economy in 2023 it just
shows how influencing is so much bigger
than just influencer itself there's also
a team to support the influencer and
people should look Beyond just like
Addison Ray or look Beyond oh Kim
Kardashian like it's people who support
them or people who are behind them and
you should look into those careers as
well alright that was wsj reporter Kalyn
Roan and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
foreign
[Music]